so what do you make of what's the the
onslaught against Christians because I
talk about it I talk about it pretty
frequently on Twitter and here and I'm
not Christian but I see what's going on
and this is now the state sanctioned
bigotry yeah that's okay
not quite state but like yeah if you
care about what the media is oh you know
you always attack white Christian men
they're all homophobes and they're all
bigots and all of this nonsense yeah and
I go to events with these people all the
time and I find them to be decent and
respectful and willing to disagree and
walk away without punching you yeah
everything else but what do you make of
just like the focus yeah well it's part
of it's part of intersectionality you
posted the quiz the other day that it
was like what's your intersectionality
score your sexuality school yes it one
of the things that you could slide was
whether or not you're a devout Christian
the more devout of a Christian you are I
guess the more privileged do you are the
lower you are in the intersectionality
scale or something like that and so I
think it's just associated because
America and the West
why is driven by by Christianity and was
driven specifically by Protestants I
mean the Revolutionary War was seen as a
presbyterian rebellion and a lot of
those people aligned anything with a
anything that is aligned with
Americanism is white nationalist is
wrong is imperialist Christianity gets
tied up in that now for evangelical
Christians we also know because the
Bible tells us that the Church of Christ
is going to be pushed to the margins
until the world comes to an end and so
we will be persecuted we will be more
and more marginalized and yes we can
continue to fight for Christian values
we continue to fight for being left
alone really is what we're really
fighting for just kind of leave us alone
that's what Protestants pretty much have
always done but yeah I mean at the end
of the day we know that it's not going
to end well for us probably yeah it's
really crappy situation like everyday
just another tweet and another story
this nonsense you know they'll do Chris
Pratt's Church and they'll try to make
me seem like oh he's a homophobe in he
goes this home before the church and
it's like
you want to do a lot of Omar's mosque
now you want to do that but they don't
want to do that yes actually they're the
bigots right that really is the truth
yeah and that's the thing is that
they're fine they're really fine the
left is fine with you being a Christian
as long as you don't actually believe
what the Bible says so as long as you
believe the stuff about feeding the poor
as long as you believe that kind of
stuff but that has to mean the
government's right is longer you're down
with that but you have to take away the
wrath of God you have to take away Jesus
being the only way truth and life you
have to take away the biblical marriage
stuff you have to take away the abortion
stuff if to take away the hard work that
proverbs talks about that even the
Apostle Paul talks about gotta take all
that away as long as you're the
Christian that believes in wealth
redistribution you're good yeah all
right so let's dive into some of the
topics of the day you mentioned the the
wage gap yeah it was recently it was
what was it gender pay gap de Arte I
don't even know I just made sure to pay
all my female employees less that day oh
really drive it home yeah is it a minute
what's going on here it's a myth because
well it's partly a myth what they don't
tell you is the entire story is this
whole uncontrolled gap through our
versus the controlled gap but I actually
heard about this originally on a more
left-leaning site that's an organization
up in Seattle that fights for equal pay
and they actually taught me on their
site the difference between an
uncontrolled gap at a controlled gap the
uncontrolled a great Twitter threat on
this by the way which will link to in
the description yeah yeah it was a
controlled gap account or I'll start
with the uncontrolled gap does not
account for a job title doesn't account
for experience as an account for hours
work
it really doesn't put any factors and
it's just the median what women make
versus the median what men make which is
79 cents to a dollar that is true but it
doesn't account for any choices or an
experience the controlls gap accounts
for all of those things so it accounts
for a job title hours worked all of that
it doesn't account for like negotiating
a raise doesn't account for end of your
bonuses or anything like that
but it does account for the big factors
and that is 99 cents on the dollar so
women make nine
in cents to every dollar that a man
makes but again you're not accounting
for a few factors there and that could
be within the margin of error so no
matter what there is no proof that there
is systemic sexism that is causing women
to make less money well it also doesn't
account for the fact that men and women
choose different careers it's the most
simple level I mean the best example of
this is Sweden rooms have been you know
completely egalitarian for ever
basically and guess what there's still
more male engineers and there's still
more female nurses yeah so now they want
to like force people to do things that
they don't actually want to do so they
can get it 50/50 which yeah that's
really how freedom works no and there's
an I mean there's a million different
programs to try to get women into stem
because they've said for so long that
the reason why there are so many more
men in stem is because women feel
intimidated and because there's this
patriarchal attitude in the stem field
while so they've tried so hard they've
put so much money behind it and still I
mean men are outpacing women or there
are so many more men in stem that I mean
just as many as there's ever been and so
it's probably not a be outside factor
it's probably because women in general
are different how much of this do you
think is just misguided sort of
confusion so for example you're pregnant
now your husband's here in the green
room your careers are gonna be a little
bit different you're gonna probably take
some time off to child rear yeah maybe
he will take some paternity time maybe
not but this but just physiologically we
just are different they don't like
talking about that yeah but that is just
the nature of reality I saw a study the
other day that was like breaking news
and it was some study out of the UK that
showed that there's a difference between
boys and girls brains inside the womb
that is is early as you know however
many weeks gestation that a child's
brain is developing and they start going
in these divergent paths of women that
just that how the neurons connect and
women kind of being grown into these
interpersonal creatures whereas men are
more focused in general on objects and
data and things women are more focused
on ideas and words and people that
starts in the womb and I'm like I'm so
glad science is finally catching up to
God
finally catching up to the things that
we've known for thousands of years and
so you do wonder if that's going to
happen if okay we're trying all of these
cool social experiments right now like
maybe oh maybe it'll be fine if we draft
women like maybe it'll be fine if we
just pretend we just are totally gender
neutral with our kids and pretend like
no binary definition of gender exists
but I do wonder if science will catch up
with us and be like actually all these
things that conservatives were saying
that the left thought were social
constructs they're just biological
reality well they also might find out
what if they found out that there was a
gay gene one day yeah now they're
pro-choice would you you have to be okay
then with a woman deciding to abort that
baby because because they don't want the
child to be gay and that does put them
in this kind of ethical conundrum I mean
but it's the same thing with with race I
mean I guess you would know what race
your child is obviously before you have
an ultrasound or anything like that but
you have I mean there is a racial aspect
to abortion and that the majority of
abortions happen in minority communities
and so when you ask a pro-choice er
about that they don't typically have any
kind of answer though all right wage gap
you briefly mentioned the trans
situation or gender roles yeah the trans
issue considering its you know Oh point
zero one yes and the population you're
saying and I have complete sympathy yeah
with the issues that they're dealing
with yes and I think that the left does
that a lot maybe I'm gonna give them the
benefit of the doubt maybe with good
intentions because people with gender
dysphoria it truly is a struggle I know
someone with gender dysphoria and it is
a struggle they didn't want this they
didn't they don't like this kind of
struggle of feeling like they don't
belong in their own body it really is a
psychological struggle but you treat it
as a struggle you treat it as something
that okay we don't just say well live
what you want to live because they
actually the rates of suicide are pretty
much equal afterwards
it doesn't actually reconcile anything
when we say okay just do what you want
to do because it truly is a disorder in
a dysphoria and I think maybe in an
attempt to be compassionate to the
people that are dealing with this and to
help them not feel ashamed the left
said you know what we're just going to
validate who you are I personally don't
think that's the compassionate thing to
do to lie to someone and I know a lot of
conservatives feel the same way but then
you do start finding yourself getting
angry and defensive about a subject that
we should have a lot of sympathy for it
because people force you to use gender
pronouns that you don't want to use they
force you to have conversations that you
don't want to have and that's where
things just get really sticky and that's
when unfortunately conservatives
including me we get really dogmatic
about it and the sympathy and compassion
is thrown out the window yeah so what do
you do to fight that because that I get
that it's tough if you just keep being
called trans Fobo or any of these folks
well eventually you're just like all
right then enough of this I'm gonna go
for the destroys tweet of the compassion
tweet well the tweets are difficult
because the tweets it's like you only
have so many characters and putting out
the nuanced compassionate tweet is
typically not what comes to mind I think
when you're just trying to put your put
your idea out there you don't have time
to add the nuance you're like I'm just
gonna get to the point I'm not saying
that's right
but that's typically my tendency and our
tendency and I don't think that's a good
thing but in conversations I always
think it's really important to define
your terms if you have a same leftist
who is saying you're a trans folk okay
well we need to define phobia and we
need to define what I believe in what
you believe and maybe we actually agree
on a lot of same things we just disagree
on the facts we just disagree on the
variables so I think defining the terms
is important it starting with what you
agree is important and then working out
from there how often do we do that maybe
not often so what would you do you think
it's fair to say that the average
conservative well first off you know the
when they keep putting phobe at the end
of fo biz an irrational fear so I assume
you don't think the average conservative
has an irrational fear of trans people
no I don't think so okay so what what do
you think the average do you think the
average conservative has the thoughts
that you laid out earlier which is sort
of a sympathy for this but then we don't
want that to override yeah our thinking
brain something like that I think some
people are saying you know what I really
don't care if you dress like a girl or
you dressed like a guy or you want to
call yourself something I just don't
want you to force that on me I don't
want you to take away for example my
religious liberty in lieu of like I
I don't know they don't want their
rights trampled upon in favor of this
small group however I do think there are
people that kind of see where this line
of reasoning goes that if okay we deny
biological realities we deny what
science is telling us and we buy into
this delusion that a man can just wake
up one day and say that he is a woman
then okay we kind of lose we kind of
lose all truth what is truth anymore
it's just what you feel we lose identity
it's just who you say you are or are you
actually defined in any way by biology
and I think they see the kind of
slippery slope that goes down and they
say okay stop right there I'm not down
with this and it all sounds crazy to
just wake up and you know middle-aged
and be like well now female but it's
like what at that point I mean this is
this sounds bananas but if you were a
washed-up male NBA player who couldn't
play in the league anymore you could be
like yeah I'm a woman today I identify
his woman right yeah I'm jumping in the
WNBA and I'm gonna be the MVP watch this
and then the feminists would have to say
yes lives experience yeah well that's
the other problem with it is that you're
kind of seen some feminists push back on
this and say hang on well old-school
feminists have been kind of saying okay
we fought for the uniqueness of women
the empowerment of women because women
are women and now men are beating us at
our own game men are better at being
women than women are that's not fair
and so I do think you see feminists
pushing back on that who truly do
believe that okay the reason why we
fought for the empowerment of women is
because women are unique only women can
have children only when we can do
certain things women are better at some
things the men are as far as leadership
goes as far as organization goes things
like that and they fought to bring those
things to the forefront and now none of
those things matter anymore because you
can be a man to be a woman so there is
just I'm just so glad I'm not on the
left it just seems so confusing it's
like all right so you're preggers you
video make men masculine again why did
they have a man do that why did they
have what was the idea we're gonna have
a woman yes talk about man male
masculinity I think it's because you're
seeing a lot of women talk about how
terrible toxic masculinity is and say ah
men they just they don't even know how
hard it is and they've oppressed us for
so long we just need them to
take a back seat and so we can kind of
step up and do our thing and so I think
they wanted the perspective of a woman
to say hang on just a second
women actually do not only do we like
masculine men or not even necessarily
traditional masculinity I'm not talking
about like writing a four-wheeler I'm
talking about taking a responsibility
for your actions and taking care of your
family taking care of that provision and
protection that men are so good at and I
think better at than women are so you
could still wear a nice shirt let's say
yes you should be able to take care of
it yeah it's more internal traits than
anything else and the actions and the
habits that you have the
responsibilities that you take women do
care about that it actually the
complementarian relationship that men
and women have had for ever has has
worked really well it's worked really
well not always I mean sometimes it goes
over to a patriarchy and that's not good
I don't think oppression of women is
good but the the yin and the yang the
back and forth and the complementarian
relationship that we've had has worked
and I think you kind of needed to hear a
woman say that so why do you think the
left's trying to destroy that because
they think a Galit arianism will equal
equality so it's equality through
homogeny which is part of why abortion
is a really big thing that they fight
for if a man can physically walk away
from an unwanted pregnancy a woman
should be able to - I mean a pregnancy
the ability to get pregnant is really
one not one of the only things but
probably the biggest thing that makes a
woman different and so if we get rid of
that through abortion and then maybe men
and women really well be the same and
maybe they really will be equal then
there'll be no abuse no oppression no
patriarchy things like that but I mean
men are always going to be physically
stronger than women and there's always
going to be bad men and bad women so
oppression won't stop abuse won't stop
egalitarianism is just going to make or
not shouldn't say egalitarianism but
sameness is going to make things more
confusing not better so I know you do
public speaking too and when you go to
colleges do you find you have any tricks
on how to wake up say some of the
lefties that are you know at least open
to some of these ideas they're kind of
like she must be the bad guy but I'll at
least go and sit in the back
well what I try to do is I try to my
message is typically when I come usually
speaking to mostly conservatives is that
okay you're hearing that you're crazy
for believing in things like border
security for being pro-life for being
Pro capitalism but here's where these
ideas come from and here's how they have
worked and really only over the past 10
to 15 years have we heard all of this
crazy intersectionality identity
politics stuff that they are acting like
is mainstream and so you're not the
extremists you're not the radical you're
not the one that's out there you're not
the Nazi and the bigot you believe
things that Americans have believed
since our founding and they have a
really good history and a really good
basis and so I don't know if that has
necessarily ever changed the leftist
mind but it is something that's
different than just talking points and
saying the leftist stupid it's saying
hey we have good ideas and you have a
right to believe they're good ideas and
you have a right to defend these good
ideas really the the most disrespectful
or the craziest I always get very
respectful great liberal students that
come and listen and ask awesome
questions I think the only time that has
been like oh my gosh I can't even get a
word out without these people screaming
is when I was at UC Berkeley and I spoke
to them oh yes and I spoke to a class
and the professor was awesome for asking
me and I actually thought when I went in
there was like I meant I have a really
tame I got a really tame with what I say
I'm not gonna say I'm not gonna throw
any flames or anything like that oh my
gosh
I couldn't even it was like they had
never heard a conservative idea they had
never heard someone who wasn't a liberal
utter a word and it was irrational it
was irrational
that was really my only experience when
I was like this is crazy
they've abandoned thought you and a
weird way blame the baby boomers for
this because it's their kids right like
or it's the end of their the young end
of their children like so anyway you
can't blame the the 16 year old who now
gets into college you know a couple
years go by
he's been indoctrinated in high school
gets to college gets slammed with more
this up I have sympathy for him well
when they're yelling at me I don't have
that much sympathy for ya but like I
have sympathy for that condition because
they were just thrown into that yeah
we're not that you're looking to blame
somebody but if you
to sort of figure out where this whole
thing started yeah where would you go
well the baby boomers really like to
talk about how terrible Millennials are
and I agree with them to some degree I
mean a lot of the stereotypes that
people have of us stare entitled in
apathetic are true but I remind them
like we were raised like we were raised
by someone we weren't raised by wolves
and I don't think it's so much that
parents probably told their kids to be
entitled or told their kids to be
spoiled I don't know if it was a lack of
values that were taught in the family
but also there was a significant change
from the time our parents were kids like
my mom for example was you know she was
driving to the liquor store to get her
dad beer when she was like 13 years old
I mean car seats like that just wasn't
even a thing I mean everything was a lot
more free to the time where we were kids
I remember there was like a new law that
said you have to be in a car seat until
you're like in second grade or something
like that everything changed everything
became more safe and everything shifted
from like the latchkey kids who were
coming home and finding for themselves
that's mostly Generation X because both
their parents had jobs too kind of these
helicopter parents and these everybody
gets a trophy or this everybody gets a
trophy mentality that we had in school
it's not like we didn't have competition
but it was that everyone gets some kind
of reward I would know I'm terrible at
running I'm so slow and yet in every
race I kind of got honorable mention
honorable mention I got something and
that's how we were raised I swear to God
so I'm Gen X so I'm a little older than
you but I swear to God I remember being
in third or fourth grade field day and I
was I was a scrawny little kid I was not
a good athlete I became a good athlete
later and I remember getting a slip
field a not place I didn't get a medal
and I remember getting some sort of
participation thing and I'm not kidding
I remember as a third or fourth grader
thinking this is nonsense
yeah like why would you give me this I
felt shitty I felt bad I sucked it
whatever we were doing like a slow bike
race another and I suck so why do you
get it right yeah we've we've sold this
yes if this is how it's supposed to be
yeah I think
it's parenting its technology its values
its purpose it's so much I mean you do
also
you can't deny just the effect the
personal technology had on Millennials
and I mean we had iPhones from the time
that we were probably 15 we had
cellphones even before that we had
MySpace xanga if anyone remembers that
you had faces I think it was before my
eyes I didn't have it but I remember
some people did you had AOL Instant
Messenger so you had personalized
technology from a really young age that
told us that everything is about you
everything is focused on you and then
the older that we got we got Netflix we
got over ease we got all of these things
that made life really convenient instant
gratification always we don't know
anything other than Amazon I don't know
how to read a map like I don't I
remember my dad trying to teach me how
to read a map in high school I was like
yeah dad okay a map is how to refold it
the rest it's like whatever but yeah
just fold it back in the way it came out
well I don't even know how to do that so
and I think most Millennials don't it so
this instant gratification things should
be easy for me as they are in the
technological world has really affected
our politics too
do you feel that the technological part
of this has actually really screwed up a
generation then like that there's
obviously a lot of goodness and we're
doing this on YouTube yeah yeah that was
that it really like we had will we
handed everybody it didn't matter what
age you are we all got handed this
incredible technology that opened the
world our hands but especially if you're
a 15 year old being handed that yeah
that's that's a lot to give a kid yeah I
want to hesitate to blame all of all of
it on technology I also see a loss of
values and that we're not only the most
progressive generation but we're also
the most irreligious generation we're
the biggest generation of religious nuns
in omes and I do think a lot of us are
wandering looking for truth not really
knowing what that is not me but a lot of
people in our generation I don't know if
that comes with technology at all or if
that's connected but it's certainly a
factor and why I think Millennials just
don't have any Center they don't have
any grounding and they just think that
their centers themselves then we're told
this all the time on social media I mean
your favorite fitness blog or your
favorite self-help author is just love
yourself if you just
look in the mirror in the morning you
tell yourself you're awesome that you're
enough then you're gonna be fine and
that's what you need to do everything's
about my happiness so you cut out the
toxic people in your life you cut out
the things that you don't like the
things that make you sad and you just do
you yeah you'll be pretty lonely yeah I
mean there's a drop it all the way right
and I mean what do you do when the self
love runs out what do you do when the
self-esteem runs out what do you do when
you wake up in the morning you're like
okay I'm not that awesome and I haven't
accomplished that much should you just
continue to coddle yourself or should
you do something about it and the
Millenial is told coddle you'll be fine
and then you have someone like aoc
saying well we're going to provide
economic security for people who are
unwilling to work and so if you will
just want to be a watercolor painter
even if you suck at it you should just
keep doing it yeah so there's not a lot
of money in watercolor paint in general
I wouldn't know cuz I'm not good at it
but I can imagine gay marriage let's
talk about it from a Christian
perspective so when we're posting this
we're holding this video for a couple
days but I just had chaperone in here
and yeah we've talked about gay marriage
and he talks about his feelings from an
Orthodox Jewish perspective and we can
we've basically gotten it to the place
where we agree to disagree and what we
agree to disagree on the on the fact
that he's not okay with it through a
religious perspective but he's not
trying to legislate my life and I as a
citizen of this country I'm completely
okay with that yeah I suspect that's
probably similar to your it is similar
now as a Christian there is a little bit
of I would say a second layer to that so
he obviously believes that homosexuality
is wrong because the Old Testament says
it we believe it not just because the
Old Testament but it's reiterated in the
New Testament and then there is this
crazy picture in metaphor that is given
to us in Ephesians 5 that says okay
marriage is a reflection of what
Christians call Christ in the church as
Christ as the head of the church so the
husband is the head of the wife and so
it's this husbands are to love their
wives as Christ loved the church and
wives are supposed to submit to their
husbands as to the Lord so there is this
spiritual component this gospel
component
- marriage being between a man and a
woman so there really is no theological
way for any Christian they try but to
get out of the dynamic that God set up
not just biologically and physically but
also spiritually and so that's where I
stand as far as a religious perspective
now I've heard both sides of it I have
heard conservatives and even
libertarians that I respect saying you
know what I just can't get behind I just
can't get behind gay marriage from even
a civics perspective or from a legal
perspective
you heard libertarians know that I've
heard I would say not anyone famous I
would say friends who probably have
libertarian views still say maybe that
was maybe they don't feel that way
anymore but just say it's so hard for me
to separate the personal from the
political but where I stand politically
is probably the same I would say
probably the same place as Ben dies I
mean one gay marriage is here to stay
there's nothing that's going to be done
about it and I don't think I are
probably any other evangelical in the
political world is going to fight
against it but I think what does that
tell you quickly about evangelicals in
general because I think this is
important I've said this many times but
it's like nobody cares about gay
marriage anymore really in the big
picture like I get your theologic yeah
yeah personal belief but in the public
political space yeah something that was
anathema to this group of people for a
long time now has become normalized
pretty quickly I think I think by and
large Christians have realized that
their communities aren't getting worse
that the neighbors next door have kids
and they're the same as everybody else
that you don't even hear Mike Huckabee
going on about it anymore or or Rick
Santorum or any of these guys they've
sort of moved on and I think this is
where I would love the progressives to
have a little humility yeah like just a
little bit of you know what me maybe you
guys were wrong right you were wrong but
then something happened and you didn't
you let it go yeah sickly and that would
show a little humanity and humility and
they just refused to do that
yeah and again this is where then I can
find myself building bridges with you
guys all the time because yeah because
there's a place to build the bridge -
yeah I think that a lot of evangelical
conservatives realized okay yes
America was founded on Christian values
and we should continue to perpetuate
those Christian values but the state
does not define marriage God defines
marriage and I think that churches
should be free to say sorry we're not
gonna we're not gonna marry two men you
know right and yeah and I knew that you
did and I think that we kind of made
that separation and say and said okay
God defines marriage in the Bible if I
don't want to get on board with it
because I am beholden to God and God
above the state then that's fine and
churches shouldn't be beholden to the
state in that regard either and I think
that we kind of decided okay that's fine
if they want to get married according to
the state's definition of marriage
that's okay but I and my congregation
are not going to change our views on it
and we just kind of want to be left
alone in that regard yeah so what would
you what do you make of when when
churches do perform gay marriages like
these yeah I'm just sort of skirting
their theological Yesi or integrity oh
yeah I mean this is a huge thing in the
United Methodist Church is that they've
kind of almost had a split because they
voted on this so-called traditional plan
saying okay if you're a Methodist Church
if you're under the United Methodist
Church umbrella this denomination you
can't perform gay marriage or you can't
yeah you can't perform you can't perform
these marriages and there were a lot of
people who are really upset about that
and but from a Christian perspective you
just can't get around it there's no way
to get there's no way theologically to
get around it without making some
serious not just physical concessions
but spiritual concessions and so my
question for anyone and it's not just
about gay marriage it's about anything
in the Bible my question is if you don't
take the Bible as God tells us to take
it why are you a Christian find a
different hobby like there's you can you
know you can be a moral person you can
yeah you can be a good person and you
can believe in feeding the poor without
following Christ but Christ tells us to
deny ourselves take up our cross and
follow him and part of that is adhering
to the word even when it's inconvenient
and not culturally cool so I'm just a
little bit confused by those theological
concessions but yes to answer your
question I do think that it's calm
on what the Bible says yeah what what do
you think that would actually in
practice what does that mean
you know you mean like so in practice
gay people start getting married now
doesn't matter outside of the church
what do you think the practice of that
would lead to in society that would be
are you talking okay outside of the
church yeah outside of the church do you
see that some sort of problem well I I
of course do you think that God's way is
better than man's way and I do believe
that God setting up marriage as a union
between a man and a woman is better I
think that it's better for I think it's
better for the family I think it's
better for children and I think because
it's better for the family it's better
for society now do I think it's going to
be the degradation of society do I think
that we're our whole thing is going to
hell in a handbasket because of that no
I don't but of course I think that the
way God set up marriage and family in
the Bible is better than how secular
society does it and yeah so that's where
I feel that I feel like we are I feel
like we'd probably be going
however homosexuality is it different or
necessarily worse than other sense is
different kind of sin because it's a
sexual sin according to Christianity but
it's not worse we don't believe that it
puts us in a worse place than all of the
other sense that America has done what's
so funny I know what's gonna happen now
so people are gonna clip this and
they're gonna go out see there's Ruben
sitting with another homophobe yeah I to
his face sitting in his house where you
live yeah you like hanging right and
it's just like I mean I said it to Ben
so I'll say it to you like as long as
you're not trying to legislate my life
yeah maybe there's a part of me that I'm
like maybe I should care more should I
be more offended or something like that
yeah I just don't well I think part of
it too is one you want to be left alone
like so many people like Christians do
to like go live your life yeah you want
to be left alone and I think also and
you can correct me if I'm wrong but a
lot of the problem that especially
Christians see on the left is that they
conflate sexuality with identity and so
if I disagree with your relationship
from a Christian perspective then that
must mean that I hate you but I don't
hate you I think that you're a great
person I think you're a smart person and
your husband's awesome and so they a lot
of people on the Left seem to not be
able to separate those two things that I
can love you as a person
and respects you and admire you as a
person and not agree from my own
Christian perspective with your
relationship now I also think it's
important to say though it's not if I
were to what Christians would say
witness to you if I were to share the
gospel with you it would not be hey Dave
you're gay and that's wrong that would
not be the message what we believe that
unbelievers people who are not
Christians are repenting from when they
come to Christ is unbelief it is not
your primarily your primary sin is that
you're gay or that you are a thief or
that you're anything else it's that you
don't believe in Christ and so that's
what we believe that we are preaching
the gospel to unbelievers to be saved
not gay people to make them straight now
we do believe that through
sanctification that we all have to
repent from our sins but I think it's
important also to distinguish that that
what we're talking about salvation
sharing the gospel with people it's not
necessarily saying our primary message
isn't that you're gay and that's bad
yeah but do you think people could just
stop being gay if they repented and
stepped well I know two different
stories there's a really good book by
someone who I totally disagree with it's
so many ways but she she wrote a good
book now she probably wouldn't say that
well God makes people strange but it's
called gay girl good god it's by Jackie
Hill Perri and she did live life as a
gay person and then she kind of had an
awakening she came to God and she's
married and she has kids there are
stories like that but I also know
stories of people there is another
amazing story and I don't want to say
the title because I'm I don't wanna say
the title but there is another
incredible story of someone who became a
Christian he lived life as a gay person
he actually was in prison and he lived
life as a gay person and he became a
Christian and he lives as far as I know
he was a celibate lifestyle and so he is
not married he is probably never going
to be married he might not ever be
attracted to women but because he is a
Christian and Jesus has called us to
deny ourselves whatever our desires are
that are simple he loves a celibate
lifestyle and so I think that wonders
makes me as deeply sad like I can get
yeah you know like really like you know
I'm pretty tolerant about this stuff
honestly that one just strikes me as he
is gay he there is this religious piece
of him in there that so the answer is
then live alone and don't have kids and
don't have a family yeah but that is
where you start completing sexuality
with identity and romantic relationships
with the ultimate fulfillment and that's
not what the Christian believes actually
Paul says for everyone it's better to be
single than to be married he says I wish
you were all like I was so you can be
fully dedicated to the Lord and we
believe that if you're straight or
straight or you're same-sex attracted
then the gift of celibacy is truly a
gift that you could dedicate all of your
passions to God so we don't see celibacy
as this sad awful lonely thing we
believe that in Christ you have full
fulfillment full satisfaction whether
you were attracted to the opposite sex
or the same sex and so I think he would
tell you great person had that I'll tell
you his name but I would think he would
tell you that he finds a full
satisfaction and full joy in his
relationship with Christ now that does
not mean it's easy right well I was
gonna say he would also sort of have to
say that to rationalize his existence
right like I'm not sure that he would I
don't think he would have chosen because
he was living an actively gay lifestyle
his name is Christopher you want and I
think he's incredible I don't think he
would have chosen to be a Christian or I
don't think he would have become a
Christian if he didn't think that there
was something to it if he didn't think
that it was worth it I mean he's seen
the two alternatives and he chose one
direction so he obviously thinks that
one is more satisfying than the other I
mean he got nothing out of at least
Anjali in this life saying okay I'm
gonna give that up and become a
Christian yeah so it makes you wonder it
does make you wonder it should make you
wonder about Christianity what is it
about Jesus that would make someone give
up what they thought their identity was
where the world says well that's where
love is is just being yourself and
loving who you want to love what kind of
God and what is there to Chris